では 皆様に新しい年が大変幸福な年になりますようにと祝致しまして
今日の話を始まるしかないんですね
まあいろいろ世間話をする時間はないと思います
えっと まあまず注意事項がいっぱいありましてね
今日のテーマは福島原発と同じぐらい気をつけないと
知ってるんだと言ばったってもね
技術は世界一と言ばってもね
ここら辺の板橋の方にもラジオ大量に見つかったという話も聞きましたしね
で あの気づきのテーマなんですけど
まあそれはまあ一旦忘れましょう
まあ別なテーマで喋ります
まあ時間があったら 本題に入ります
まあ理由がございまして
これ今あの 今世間でね
結構流行ってますけどね
気づきの瞑想っていうのはね
しかし このミャンマーのマハーシーシャードが
一般のミャンマーの一般の方々に瞑想を教え始めて
それはどんどん広げてしまっちゃって
一般社会に知られるようになりましたけど
やっぱりあまりこの道場の外に行かないというデータっていうのはものすごい大量にあるんです
で この気づきは簡単に見えそうですけど
いまだ誰もこの 気づきって何やと
そのサイコロジカルファンクションという
この いわゆる科学的に心理学的にどういうカラクリでこうなるのかっていうことね
これは説明しません 普通は結構難しいんです
お釈迦様はじめ あんまりこの一般の方々にそこをわかるようにしてないんだから
なんで私はそうしなくちゃいけないかっていうね
個人的な疑問もあります
ですから できるだけこういう
いわゆるサイエンティフィックアナリシスというかね
そういう客観的に分析することはできるだけ避けます
それから皆様も一応イントロダクションのところはお読みになったと思いますけどね
日本ではいろいろいくつかね
意味があるんだということでね
それは私も全然興味ないんです
そのパリパラで発表しているテーマに沿って喋る興味は全くないんで
作る時はまあなんとか喋りましょうと思ったんですけどね
忘れちゃって で 後から読んでみたら面白くないということで
ちょっとテーマ 別なアプローチに入ります
で あの気づきを忘れてください
まずはあの現象の これはどんな感じでも構いません
世界ということを勉強してみましょう
で 一番ポイントは まあ私たちは一人一人がね
そんな私には幻覚あるわけないでしょうと
と思ってるんですけど
全ての生命の認識システムが
幻覚を作るようにできているんです
一人二人に限ったわけではなくて
生命だったら 幻覚現象の問題があるんです
何で書いたんですか？ 現象じゃ現像って書いてあったんで
あ そう でも幻覚の幻の漢字が消えましたんですけど
それが大事なんです へへへ
へ で この生命っていうのは
命って何ですかというと
至って簡単 認識があるんですね
物事を感じるんですね
ミミズであろうか ダニであろうか
何か感じているんですね
だから石ころ ビー玉と違います
ビー玉は何も感じません
ダニは結構 周りを感じるんですね
だから目が歩かないかって問題じゃなくて
まあある形の物体があって
そこは感じているんですね
そこを私は認識システムと呼ぶんですね
認識なんです それで 皆様はダニなんか大したことわかってないだろうと思ってるでしょ？相当幻覚ですよ
皆様には ただ 幻覚の程度が多いか少ない
それだけの話です はい
それはどうでもいいんですけど
その認識するときは この心があるプロセスがあって
そのプロセスで幻覚を作って
もう認識にするんですね
情報を主観で組み合わせて作り出した世界なんですね
それで私が知ってる世界っていうのは
私の体に触れる タッチする情報を自分なりに処理して
プロセッシングして 自分の主観で
で あ 知りましたということにするんです
で はい そういうことだから
まあ例えば 何か動いているものがあって
それを私も見る で 私は自分なりの幻覚を作る
猫ちゃんもそれを見ている
猫ちゃんは猫ちゃんの世界で
で 幻覚を作る だから そのその生命にとって
そのある体形できてますから
猫が動くものを見て何感じるのか
何が面白いのかさっぱりわかりませんだけど
こちらには別な認識なんですね
で ゴキブリを見て美味しいか美しいか
気持ち悪いかとかね それぞれ生命にとって違いますよ
あのゴキブリも結構美しいんですよ
知らない 他のゴキブリだけに聞いてみてください
もう一匹のゴキブリはこう
気持ち悪いゴキブリやこれやと思わない
思わないでしょ 仲間だから
ですから そちらでもね
オスのゴキブリはメスを追っかけていくんですよ
美人がいるんだから なんとかナンパしなくちゃいけないんだとかね
で ゴキブリ同士でどのように世界を知ってるかっていうことは我々はわからない
だから原っぱに生えてる草を見て
私たちはなんておいしい食べ物でしょうか
と思わないでしょ しかし
ヤギやら牛やらそれを見るととてもおいしくて
そこら辺に行くんですよ
はい そういうことで これはすごいわかりやすい例で
体によって認識が変わりますということなんです
それで我々人間は同じ認識をしているかというと
そうでもないんです 我々の体はそれぞれ違いますからね
だから 私にこの世はなにどのように見えるかと
皆様には知る方法もないんです
皆様にどのように見えるかと
私にも知る方法がないんです
そこでポイントは 私の目がある形で情報を見えるようにする
それが正しいんですかね
目の形 機能 それぞれ人によって違いますから
生命によって違いますから
どちらの視覚認識が正しいんですかね
客観的な事実に近いんですかね
それが大きな問題なんです
だから そのポイントは世界世界ではなかなか扱われませんね
議論もしません ディスカッションも何もないでしょう
だから参考に何か心理学と哲学
なんだらかんだら本でも調べたって何もないんです
だからもう結構人々は仏教のアイデアパクっちゃって
我が自分のアイデアをね
世に出してるでしょ 仏教もそこら辺ではかなり自分の特許というか
コピーライトをちゃんと握ってます
わかりやすく書いてないんです
それだけはパクれません
今日の講演の後はどうするかわかりませんだけど
私はもう本当にできるだけわかりにくく喋ろうかなと思ってるんです
はい それで でも真剣に考えてください
で 私の目 私の耳 私の舌で
私の体で感じて世界を知ってますけど
それはこの肉体の状況によって変わるでしょ
私の耳の音を感じる能力によって
私は何を聞いているのかっていうことはそこで決めているんです
で 他の人はもう全然別な音だと思いますよ
私はかなり昔ね まあもういろいろスピーカーで音楽とかなんとか聞いたりしてね
まあヘッドフォンで音楽ってすごいな
この音は とかね このスピーカーとかね
欲しいなとか思ったりしたんですけど
金がなくて買わなかったし
今調べるんですよ 一番いい
信じられないスピーカー
でもヨドバシとかあっちこっち行ってね
まあスピーカー 1個 大体 500 万とかもあるものあるんだけど
音を聴いて これに 500 万払うバカがいるのか
なんでこの音は？と あの
あの秋葉原かな あのすごい高級スピーカー
もう若者がね 一生懸命私にデモンストレーションしてくれる
すごいでしょうねとかね
本人がびっくりしてますけどですよ
っていう感じで どうなってますかね
私の耳は だから本当に私はわからないんです
最近 最新技術によって作っているスピーカーの音は最低最悪か
私の耳が音を聞き取ってないか
あるいはスピーカーも良くて
耳も良くて 私の脳が 心が
それは美しい音として処理しないか
どちらかわからないんです
それで私はその若者ね
あのね 同じブランド 同じ機械なんですけど
なんでこれが 8万円高くて
これが機能全部同じでしょうと
どう見ても あんたそれ説明してくださいと
8 万か 10 万ぐらい高いお金取ってるんで
全部同じなんです 言ったら
あの これスピーカーが違いますよと
同じく見えても ああそうと
でも納得いきませんけど
これぐらい値段高いっていうのはね
言ったら では比べてみましょうということで
同じ音楽を一つの機械で聴いて
別な機械で聞いて 随分違いですね
違うでしょ それいえ 同じですよって言えないんだからね
いいえ 同じですよって言えないんだから
まあね そういえば まあいろいろ違いますねとか言ってごまかったんだけど
私の耳にはまあ大変 何が違うかよくわからないね
はい そこで 猫はどんな音の世界にいるのか
犬はどんな音の世界にいるのかと
わかってますか？あのカエルさんにもね
絶対に音を聞こえるでしょ
じゃあカエルさんがどんな音の世界にいるんでしたかね
で 一般的な この世間にある物理学的な世界から見ても
例えばあの音っていうのは
あの形によって伝わるものの形によって音がちょっと変わりますからね
だから同じ音をウサギさん聞く
我々は聞くとどうなるのかと
我々の耳がこんなもんだからね
ちゃんと振動しない ウサギさんがあれは必ず耳を合わせますからね
音をキャッチする なんか楽器ありますね
なんかいろいろ そんな感じで音をキャッチしているです
だから何聴いてるかわからないんですね
一つだけ知ってるのは
ウサギさんはクラシックは聴かない
演歌も聴かない それだけなんですけど
でも ウサギさんにも音の世界あるでしょ
それで耳ぶたが全くないカエルさんはどうでしたね
はい それで私が仏教から言いたいポイントは
えらい不安じゃないんですかね
本当に私たちは知ってる世界
そうなんですかね だから二人がいたら
いたら二種類の知識なんですね
同じスピーカーの音であっても
10人聞くと その 10種類の
知覚なんですね それぞれ体によって
脳のプロセッシング能力によって聞く
聞いた 知ったということが変わるんです
そういうわけで 私の知る世界が私のこの体の中に閉じ込まれてあって
本当にそうなのかということは
知る方法も存在しないんです
科学的にはいくら研究してもこれだけは無理なんです
脳をいじって何か反応があるんだと言うかもしれませんだけど
何を感じるのかということはわからないでしょう
ですから 世の中は知識っていうのはものすごくありがたがるでしょ
科学知識やらあれやこれやとか
芸術的な能力とか なんだ芸術っていうのは
まあいっぱい金かけていろんなオブジェとか作ってるでしょ
あれって見る見ればみんな美しいと思うんですかね
カラスにとっては まあ糞をかけるためにはいいところやって
そんな程度でしょうに
カラスの目の能力は人間よりもはるかに優れてますけど
結局は私の認識が私の主観で勝手に作るものであって
客観的なデータとは何の関係もなくなっているんです
だから 子供たちがいろんなもどき
もどき遊び いろんなことをしたりして遊んでるでしょ
ものすごく妄想にふけて
妄想の世界で 生命はみんなそういう同じことをやっています
自分だけの世界を作って
それこそ素晴らしいやっていう風に思っているだけで
みんなあの夢 幻覚 その状況は仏教ではいろんな言葉で表現しています
だいたい 40種類以上言葉がありますけど
そこを訳できません だからね
あの いくつかはこの夢
幻覚 幻 蜃気楼 なんです
はい それからですね 問題が起こるのは
私は知っている 感じている
経験している 考えている
理解している わかっている
調べているなどをしますね
我々はそんな気分でいます
私は知っています 知っています
ニューヨークに行ったことは？行ったことあります
と そう 私も行きましたよと
二人よく知ってるつもりですけど
それ経験しているというね
この私はというところがポイントでした
だからちょっと色を変えておきました
その言葉で全てまとめるんで
自分の幻覚を まとめて
それ事実だとするんです
何？あれはとても美しいですよと
例えばディズニーランドの夜のパレード
あれ すごいびっくりしましたよ
美しいですよと なんでそう言うのか
私は見たんだから だから私は見たんだから事実です
これ 話にならんでしょうに
人にはこれが事実 真実です
でしょ？自分が聞いたこと
見たもの 味わったもの
考えたもの 触ったものは
自分にとっては事実です
真実です 幻幻覚じゃないんです
しかし それは主観で作り上げた
合成した 組み合わせた概念です
この花は美しいといっても
それは私のこの体の中で組み立てて
からくるいろんなことをやって作った概念なんです
花の状況は何やとわかったことじゃないんです
だから目を通すとデータがいろいろ変わりますからね
それが知識範囲 認識範囲です
簡単に読めるかもしれませんだけど
なかなか難しいんです
我々の知る世界 知られる世界
膨大だと思ってるでしょ
本当に小さい小さいんです
それも幻覚 組み立てた
合成したものなんです
はい そのポイントから世の中の知識に対してちょっと考えてください
どれぐらい知識 技術 能力
世の中にあると思いますかね
見たらびっくりするほどあると思ってるでしょ
本当はないんです ものすごく分厚いバカでかい本も書いたり
もうもう一人 人間にはもうほんの僅かしか知れないぐらい大量に人類の文化ではなくて
遺産というか 何と言うんですかね
人間の財産と すごい知識能力あるだろうと
考えるだけでね あのマヤ文明の人々もね
すごい知識がありましたよとかね
あの 天体の動きとか精密に計算しましたよとかね
いろいろ喜んでますけどね
12月23日でしたっけね
それで終わりですからね
じゃあ早く勉強してください
もうあまり時間ないんです
はい それではこれは仏教の立場で
仏教の立場から見れば
生命っていうのはね 何も知らんやと
ただ幻覚を作っちゃってね
俺は知ってる 俺は知ってる
いい加減にしろよと 何も知らんだろうと
ですから そこで次のまあ
社会道徳的なアプローチに入りますけど
生命っていうのはみんな異なるんですね
同一生命は二人いません
ありえません 同じ細胞で分かれたこの一卵双生児っていう同じじゃないんです
それぞれ別々なんです
時々ね あの この昆虫とかね
あの卵 300個とかね
んで 孵化して見えないほど小さなもう新しい命がたらっと出ていくでしょ
私はそれを見て 一個一個一個違う命やと
本当に虫眼鏡でなければ見えないぐらい小さな生命見るでしょう
でも一個一個違います
似てないんです なぜ私とあなたは似てないのですか？っていうこと
みんな仲間探してるでしょ？自分と同じ考え
同じ好き嫌い 何もぶつかることなく
そんな生命はいないんですよ
なぜ私は もっと簡単に書いてあります
なぜ私はパンが好きなのに
あなたはご飯が好きですか？と
毎日の出来事でしょ ぶつかるでしょ
そういう問題に いつでも
もう人間同士であっても
いろんなところでぶつかってます
一人がパンが好きと言うし
もう一人がいいご飯の方がいいやと言うし
なんででしょうかね それは一人一人生命が違うんだからなんですよ
生命の認識世界が互い違いからです
だから パン食べる人にはなんか別な
なんかすごい気分のいい認識が生まれるでしょう
だからその人はパンが好きと発言する
パン食べてみたって もう大した感動しないで
ご飯食べる時 まあ気持ちよく感動する人は
私がご飯が好きだと言うんです
だからそれぞれの認識が違いますからなんです
反応も感情もまた互い違います
何かに反応する みんな同じ反応しません
いろんなものに我々ずっと反応してきてるでしょ
寒さに反応するし で このホールに入ったらまた反応変わっちゃうし
外に出たらまた変わるしね
それも一人一人が違います
それから感情も違います
そういうわけで あるのは私だけの世界なんです
これも びっくりすることで嘘ですね
それも結局は だって幻覚ですから
私は私だけの嘘の世界を作って
えらいもうすべて知ってる気分でいるんです
自分だけの現象の世界を作って
それが事実だと思って生きているんです
どうしようもないんで
これがもうハメられているんです
ただ 私はパン食べたら美味しい
あ これは結構美味しいなと思ったらどうしますかね
いえ 違いますよと あの田中さんがそれを美味しくないと言ってるんだから
美味しくなるはずがないんだと思えるんですかね
私は猫を見て ああ なんて可愛いですかと思っちゃうし
ちょっと待ってくださいと
田中さんが猫が嫌いだから可愛いじゃないでしょ
こいつはと そんなややこしいことできるわけないでしょ
どうにもならん  ん あのパンダは笹の葉っぱね
美味しそうに食べてるんだからといって
私たちが食べてみたら美味しくなると思いますかね
それはもう私たちにとってはどうにもならん
あれはまずいんですね
そういうことで 私が正しくデータプロセッシングしないで認識していますが
それが私にとって事実です
私の世界は他人に知ることは
経験することは不可能です
これは結構明るい情報です
あなたのことはこの無数の生命の中で誰一人知りませんと
思ってるでしょ？子供のことならよく知ってますとかね
伴侶のことなら知ってますよとかね
あれはうちのお母さんだから
お母さんのことは私はよく知ってますよとか
知りませんよ 全く だから暗黒の中にいるような感じなんです
何にも もう自分の体感じるだけ
そこは何もわからない
それ以外は 経典にこういう文章がありまして
この宇宙はすごい ものすごい膨大ですからね
で お釈迦様がこのこの巨大な宇宙の中で
このものすごい強烈な
この太陽の光も行かないところがあるんだよと
一箇所ではなくてね もうそういうところもありますよと
光もさえも入らないんだ
ということは どれぐらい暗黒かっていうことでしょ
そちらにいる生命も こちらにも生命がいるんだよと
しかし その生命は自分だけいるんだと思ってるみたいですね
だって他の生命がいるということは知らないんです
そこで人間にはわからないんだけど
ブッダに対しては人間にどう考えてもわからない力がいろいろありますよと
一つは このお釈迦様が悟った時と
最初に説法した時とか
なんかある特定の光が宇宙に行くみたい
その光だけはあのブラックホールにも行きますよと
それで生命 あら 結構いるんだなと
あの時だけわかるんだと
私一人だけと思っていたのにとかね
まあそこまでどうかわかりませんだけど
まあ一応そういうふうにもの面白く
そのエピソードみたいな感じで書いてますね
これは本当に我々はブラックホールで生活しなくたっても
今も同じことなんです
自分が知っている世界で生きているだけなんです
私の世界が貪瞋痴の感情で汚れて
常に多数巻きが起きているんです
そこで私の目に耳にデータが入ります
入ったものはもう認識に入れ替えるんです
その時は結構ややこしい出来事が起こるんです
その上これで貪瞋痴があってね
まあたくさん感情があって
三つだけ 三つはメインですからね
でももうごちゃごちゃになってますよ
心の中が 大変な状態なんです
自分だけの世界でも穏やかにいればいいんだけど
これ決してこのうちだけの世界は穏やかじゃないんです
激しい暴風 荒波 いっぱい
混乱しているんです はい
今日はサイドに出してないんですけど
世の中の問題って何ですかというと
これなんですよ あの人言ってることは私には気に入らないんだと
それでトラブルが起こるでしょ
だからあなたに気に入らなくないんだからといって
どうすればいいんですかね
いくらそんなこと言わないでください
言ったっても 私に気に入らないと思ったら気に入らないんですよ
だってこういうシステムだから
そこでそういうふうにこれデータ処理するんですね
だから普通に喋っても難しいでしょ
この同じ会社だから 喧嘩しないで仲良くしてください
言っても聞く やっぱり嫌な同僚というんですか
人がいて もう仕事に行ったっても
あの人がいるんだから気持ち悪くてとか言うんです
でもそんなこと思ったら苦しい
もうやめなさいよと 仲良くしなさいよと
一緒にずっと仕事する仲間でしょうにと
言うのは簡単ですけど
実行できんです だから私たちはあらゆる面で他の生命とぶつかっているんです
時々誰かを見たら 私の心の中でああ
いい人だなとか この人は可愛いなとかね
自分の心の中でそうやってプロセッシングするんです
あいつを その人は可愛いかどうかさっぱりわからないんですよ
美しいか醜いか そんなのはもうわからない
こちらの主観で ああ 美しい人だ
可愛い人だとか認識しちゃうと
その人を追っかけていくんです
あれやこれやして その人はもう自分のものにとってやると
そこでトラブっちゃうでしょうに
やばいんですよ 誰かに
あ この人は可愛いと思われたら
もうとんでもないことになっちゃうんです
また 誰かが私のことを見て
ああ 気持ち悪い人だと思ったら
もうどうしようもないんですよ
だからその人の人生も危ないし
私の人生も危なくなっちゃうんです
それが我々は生きている
毎日生きている世界なんです
いつでもあれでこれでぶつかったりしていて
理由がいたって簡単 あなたは自分のことしか知らないやと
それも事実ではありませんと
幻覚やと これが解決する方法っていうのは存在すらしないんです
どうやって解決するのかいと
はい それから我々は二次災害
三次災害とか災害を起こすんです
で 認識は主観で幻覚です
この認識に怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら落ち込みやら
いろんな感情を入れてしっかり固めるんです
それからそれ正しいとも思っているんです
煩悩は煩悩を作るんです
だから何かものを見て
私は怒りを作ったならば
それから私の中であの怒りはさらに新たな新たな怒りを生み出すんです
何か見たところで欲が出て出て出てきたら
例えば電車にいると誰か見ちゃって
ああ 可愛い人やとか欲が出たとしましょう
電車に降りてもまだあれやるんですね
家に入ってもまだあるんです
寝ていてもまだそれで夢で回転するんです
だから煩悩は煩悩を生むんです
妄想はさらに妄想を作る
悩み苦しみはさらに悩み苦しみを作る
これってあの 原発と同じ
一応核反応を起こしたら
まあ次から次 次から次で止まりません
その上 普通ね 私たちはね
あの いろんな悩みで 苦しみで
仕事はないんだとかね
仕事はあるんだけど 給料は足りませんとかね
まあ仕事は楽しい 仕事はありますけども
一緒に仕事する二人がいて
気にならない この二人はとかね
そういう感じで 毎日我々はものすごい激しく苦しんでるんです
時々料理本を見ながらその通りに料理作って出しても
味が薄いとかね この味が濃いすぎやとか言われるでしょ
どうしますかね そこで作った人は女性だったらすぐ喧嘩売るでしょ
喧嘩を売ったって これどうにもならんですね
適当に味付けをしたのに
ある人にはこれが味が強すぎですねと言っちゃいます
ある人がこれ薄味でもう食べられません
もっと醤油でもかけましょうと
ということになってしまうんです
まあ具体的な例 今皆様がご飯をいろいろ食べる時は何の躊躇なく醤油をかけたりするでしょ
私は絶対かけません 書いちゃうとまずくなっちゃって
びっくりするんで なんでこれ醤油かけるの？と
はい あるいはかなり前で店に行って
まあ魚塩焼きでしたっけね
で ご飯と食べてるんですけど
魚の体の上にいっぱい塩があって
私はそれを全部取ったり取ったり取ったりして
塩入ってる皮もむいたりして
で 魚とご飯 焼き魚とご飯食べてますけど
もう一人男性が隣の で
この人も同じ料理を注文しちゃったんですね
それであの真っ白くなってるのに塩があってね
この上にダーッて醤油かけて味が無いんだと
でしょ だから私には 私は一応仏教の世界を知ってるんだからね
全然これ私にとってはただ研究だけですけど
なるほど この下には あの焼き魚
焼く前にかけた塩は入れすぎで
この方にはその塩も足らなくて
またその上醤油もかけていると
じゃあこれ皆様ならどう解決してくれる？できますかね
私もバンバン醤油食べる人間に教えてあげることは
まあ食べないわけじゃないんですよ
まあそういう時々罠にはめられる時もありますからね
どうしても醤油かけて食べなくちゃあかんとかね
時々ご親切に先生 この冷やっこにちょっと醤油とか入れてくれる時もありますから
それ食べますけど 私には冷やっこは醤油なくても食べられます
食べる気がない時はかけます
それでも頭おかしくして
なんとかしてお腹に入れるぞとかね
お腹が空いてやっぱりご飯食べなくちゃっていう場合は
まあそのままでも食べられます
まあだから だからそうやってこの研究してみてください
そうして私はこの悪口言ってるように聞こえますけど
私はこれ あの いろいろ調べて研究しているんですよ
それで人間の付き合い方で
親と子供の間でいろいろトラブルが起こる
大変ですよ その上で またあまりにも心の中でむちゃくちゃな人々は
なんで俺は生まれたんですか？とかね
生まれてから俺はどこに行くのかい？とかね
何考えてるんですかと
ろくに花が綺麗やとも見えない人は
目の前にある花が綺麗かどうかとも我々には認識不可能なのに
やっぱり私は神様が人間を作ったと思うよ
勝手に思えと 哲学まで作るんです
神がいるかいないか 魂はあるか
あるという言うし 魂はないという人もいるし
物質だけやと そういうことが頭の中にまた絡み合うと
また生きづらくなるんです
そういうわけで もう我々はものすごい
無知な上で何も 無知っていうのは痴はないなんです
だから痴っていうのは
このぐちゃっとなってますからね
自分で勝手な知だから
それを正しい知じゃないないんですから
パーリ語でも同じ単語で
これを漢字当てる時も
知という漢字に無入れたら無知ないって意味なんです
だから無知な上でいろいろトラブルがあるね
その上人と戦う なんで他人と戦いますか？知ってます？やっぱり自分が勝手に麻薬中毒みたいな
勝手に作った幻覚世界と相手が勝手に麻薬中毒が作ってる幻覚世界が合わないんだから
合うはずもないでしょ
初めからもう合いませんよとわかっておけばいいのに
で あの人のあれが悪いと言って戦いに行くんです
他人を恨むでしょ なんで恨むんですかね
あなたの幻覚でしょうにと
嫉妬するでしょ その人の幻覚のせいで
かわいそうに 誰かさんがひどい目に遭うんです
人と論争論する それから他人を支配してやるぞと思っております
人を騙す 裏切る 宗教や哲学を作る
これも病気なんです 儀式
儀礼 行などをする やってますね
占い 迷信などに依存する
自分の幻覚の問題なんです
やっぱり占ってみなくちゃとかね
この不安が消えないんだとかね
やっぱり祈祷してもらわなくちゃとかね
いろんなことを思ったりするんです
それは 2次災害  3次災害なんです
それから夢を作る 希望
願望を膨らませる 結構やってますよ
一個の体を持って その中でやっている
この恐ろしいことっていうのは
行動に移すれば 一人の人間に
何十万人でも人を殺せるんだから
一人が幻覚を作ったら
自分の国でもね みんな仲良く生けていたんですけど
ある人があんまり勉強もできなくて
僕はちょっと勉強もちょっとできなかったら
社会でちょっと立場がないんですね
まあいい仕事もなくなっちゃうし
だから勉強できない人々はちゃんと引っ込んで
なんとかそういう適当な仕事をして生活しているんですけど
ある人がまあ中学も卒業できなくて
これでこいつはもう妄想しちゃって
もう自分を差別されているんだと
こいつすら殺さなくちゃいかんかって言って
もうもしかすると  20万人
30万人ぐらい  30年間近いもう戦争でしたからね
テロリストたちとの だから頭イカれた一人の妄想のせいで
どれほど人々が それで同時に西洋の方もね
みんなイカれてるんだから
その人を応援して金あげたり
金あげたり 今日の新聞でもイギリスでも記念切手発売
もう テロリストの はい
今まで私は説明したものは
仏教用語でパパンチャという言葉を使うんですね
カタカナで書いてないんで
読み方そのままでパパンチャ
パパンチャ これパーリの単語を覚えた方がいいとは思います
それはまあ 世の中の人々を考えない言葉ですからね
まあインドの言語ですけどね
パパンチャっていうのはデータが勝手に触れますからね
目がある限り 視覚を引き起こすデータがずっと入ってるんですね
耳がある限りもう入りますよ
入るデータが自分なりに処理するんです
だから私たちが何か言っても
相手が言ったことじゃないでしょ
理解するのは 別なことを理解するんです
情報を捏造して 自分だけの特有の世界を作って
その概念にしがみついて執着して
吾輩は何でも知っているという調子で生きていることは
動詞でパパンチェーティと言うんです
だから これは他の言語では訳できないんです
これ動詞パパンチェーティなんです
パパンチャといえば名詞です
この動詞で考えると ものすごいインパクト強く
この恐ろしさはわかりますけど
なかなか日本語になってくると
やっぱり日本語っていうのは動詞が弱い言語ですからね
名詞並んでするとか何とかしなくちゃいかんですね
だから捏造するというふうに入れなくちゃいけないんですね
例えば食べるは動詞でしょ
それ 基本的な動詞はありますけど
ちょっと難しいことを考えると
まあやっぱり動詞がなくなっちゃうんですね
だからまあ我々はパーリ語をそのまま使うんです
はい この言葉難しい 知らないんだから難しいかどうかわからないでしょうね
覚えておいて この意味は今までずっと喋ったのはその意味なんです
草束を見たら 山羊はパパンチェーティ
美味しいものやと食い物やと
私はただの草だろうと
で 私はパパンチ そのようにするんです
ブッダはパパンチャを破ることをニッパパンチャ
を推薦します だから当然これはもう解決不可能な問題です
しかし お釈迦様が推薦するパパンチャを破ってくださいと
幻覚を破ってみてください
それで初めて無知の網が落ちるんです
ニッパパンチャっていうのは同義語ありまして
涅槃という同義語もニッパパンチャですね
お釈迦様はニッパパンチャータタガタ如来は如来たちはニッパパンチャであると
はい 我は思うというテーマに入ります
もう説明しなくても 理性のあるならば
まあそれからわかると思いますけどね
ムーランパパンチャサンカーヤマンターアスミーティサッバムプルンデヤーカーチタンナーアジャッタンターサンヴィナヤサダーサトウシッケ
はい スッタニパータというテキストで
今日の話にほとんど参考にしたのはスッタニパータです
日本語訳もありましてね
だからな この世の何にもとらわれず
心の炎を消して安穏に達する方法は何ですか？とブッダに尋ねたんですね
ある人がブッダに質問したんです
今は我々はいろんなことで絡み合ってるでしょうに
と思ってるでしょ あの人この人
あれやこれやとか いろんなここにあったり
もう大変だ大変だとかね
そういう何にもなくて
心の中であのすごいもう竜巻とか何もなくって
安穏穏やかでいられない
その方法は何ですか？とお釈迦様に聞いたんです
その答えの一部はスッタニパータの九百二十二の偈なんですね
答え長い ちょこっと長いんですけど
一偈だけ前出したんです
我は思うとは思うとはパパンチョを作る原因です
これ偈の意味なんです
我は思う これでパパンチが出てくるんだよと
ネッスソ 幻覚 主観 その原因を根絶すること
だから我は思うということを破ってくださいと
それで終わりだと また何かの渇愛が残ったならば
常にサティがあることでなくなるのですと
やっとサティが入りました
我は思うというところが問題だと
例えば私 普通そうでしょ
あんたにこの壁見える？このスクリーン見える？と聞くでしょ
はい 見えます 見えますと
私に見えますって意味でしょ
それが問題なんです マンタアスミという言葉
我は思うとは一切の悩み苦しみの原因です
だから喧嘩 戦い 争い 怒り
嫉妬 憎しみ あれやこれや
すべて私が思う 知る そこから出てくるんです
そこで皆様に身に身覚えあるでしょ
我は思うゆえに 何でしたっけ
どれでアホかとわかりますかね
その人は こんな恐ろしいこと
推薦して世間に提供するんだから
これが問題だよとお釈迦様は遠い昔おっしゃったんです
デカルトさんよりもかなり前に
これでやんたけど もうよろこび
そんなケンカやら怒り
嫉妬 憎しみで互いに 苦しんでいるんだよ
はい それで一つ終わって
ものすごい 次にもっとごっつい難しい経典がありまして
一部紹介します これマドゥピンディカ・スッタといいます
このマドゥピンディカはどう訳すればいいかよくわかりませんだけど
この甘いものですね これは一つもう玉にして
ピンディカっていうのはまあ
おにぎりみたいにね まあもう丸くすることですね
で すごく甘くて そういういわゆるすべて言いたいことは一つに集約したって意味なんです
まどっていうのは甘いという意味でもあって
この本当の意味 それはおにぎりにしてあげますよと
世界にあるすべての味をあなたにちょっとしたおにぎり一つに入れてあげますよというような感じだと
おにぎり 1個ぐらいは簡単に食べられるでしょう
それで知るべきことを一切ひと握りにして教えている経典です
で まあ簡単にいきましょう
ダンダパニバラモンが釈尊に聞くんです
このバラモン お釈迦様はどこかの森で座って
昼午後あたりで座っていたんです
このダンダパニって態度でかいバラモンなんですね
その人はこの杖を使うんですね
自分の立場を示すために
杖を使ってかっこよく散歩をしながらお釈迦様を見てお釈迦様に質問するんですね
それで経典でわざと書くんですね
あの自分の杖にこうやって体を支えて
立ったまんまで質問するんです
これは仏教では 世界ではものすごい行儀悪いことなんです
で 親切には答えません
その場合は お釈迦様が座っているならば
本人も礼しるかそれはどうでもいいんです
本人も座って質問しなくちゃいけなかったんですけど
こんな年寄りのバラモンが立ったままで質問したんです
あなたは何論者ですかと
いわゆるあなたの なんて言いますかね
あなた あなたのドクトリンはね
あんた 世の中に何を教えてる人ですかと
あんた何を教える人かと
そういう質問するんです
何を語るのかと お釈迦様の答え
結構長い 人間天界含むこの世で
神々 魔 梵天 シャモン バラモン
人間という誰とも何についても逆らうことなく
ぶつかること 逆らう何もなく
欲に対する執着をなくして生きている聖者が一切の疑いなく
一切の後悔なく 存在 非存在に期待なく
また思い 概念ですね 思いを蓄えることなくいられる方法を論じていますと
それを語ってますと わかりやすいでしょ
一切の生命と何の関わりもなく
心の中であの怒りやら欲やらもうない
もうこれはパパンチャの説明なんですけど
何も概念ないって パパンチャがないってこと
こちらパパンチャという言葉を使ってないんです
そこで結果どうなったんですかね
バラモンが首をこうやって
ベロを出して 額にシワを持って
何よな この人はと 出ていくんです
あのバラモンには全くきれいさっぱりわからなかったんです
だからそこはお釈迦様のすごいところなんですね
あの態度でかいし あんた何を言う人ですかねという態度で聞いたでしょ
はい こういうことを言ってますよと
だからなめるんじゃないよってお釈迦の態度なんです
この愚かどもたちは だからといって間違っていることをおっしゃっているわけじゃなくて
もう濃縮して仏教は何かと教えたんです
わからないんです だからバラモンがお釈迦様にベロを出して出て行ったんです
お釈迦様がその旨を比丘たちに報告すると
比丘が比丘がその言葉の意味を尋ねるのです
お釈迦様が今日こんなことがありましたよと
ダンダパニがこういう質問をしたと
私はこういうふうに答えましたよ
その人がベロを出して
首もなんとかして出て行ったよと
でも比丘たちにもわからないんですね
あまりにも難しくて この言葉は
だから説明してくださいと
そこでお釈迦様が ここでパパンチャという言葉を使うんです
ヤトーニダーナン ビックー プーリサン パパンチャ サンニャ サンガー サムダーチャランティ エッタチェナッティ アビ
ナンディタッバン アビワディタッバン
アジョシタッバン 人は捏造した概念を使う理由
また日本訳わからないんですね
私の訳だからね まあ難しい単語全部落としてわかりやすいところだけ訳しますから
人は捏造するんですね
みんなパパンチャするんです
その理由は何ですかと
前の偈で説明しました
マンタハマスミ 私が思う
それをお釈迦様は言わない
この場合は 理由も説明しない
人はパパンチャを作る原因があるでしょと教える
それにとらわれてはならない
喜んではならない って言うんです
では 皆様にもわかると思います
人はパパンチャをする理由は
私が思うという私という概念ですね
だからこの私はそんなこととらわれないでくださいと
喜ばないでください 執着しないでくださいと
ただそれだけで ラーガーヌセアナン
心の中でどんどんどんどん生まれてくる
この潜在的に生まれてくる欲があるんです
あの突然人を見て欲が出たんじゃなくて
常になかなかちょこちょこちょこちょこと生まれているんです
自分でわからないんです
それを潜在煩悩というんです
それからパティガーヌセヤン
怒りの潜在煩悩 ディッティ
見解 何か意見を作る 見解の潜在煩悩
ヴィチキッチャ 疑い どうだろう
どうだろう 何だろうとかね
という疑の潜在煩悩 慢の潜在煩悩
ババラガーヌセイ 存在欲という
生きていきたいでしょ
だから煩悩は立派にあります
それからアヴィッジャ
無明 無知という潜在煩悩がなくなるんだと
たったあれだけで パパンチャ作る原因なくせではなくて
気にすんなよと そんなのはもう放っておけと
だから私が私がというところはね
消えちゃったら それで煩悩が生まれることはストップするんです
ただそれだけで 武器を持つこと
戦うこと 物別れ 紛争 それから嫌味を言うこと
で 二枚舌でしたっけ まあそうです
噂をすることなどはなくなるんだと
これは私たちは勉強する経典で
もう私たちにとってはもうもの最高のサ
経典なんですね 一行二行で全て教えてるんだから
それからもう怖いものはないっていう感じで説法できるんです
だから世の中にある嘘をつくわ
泥棒するわ 邪淫 よこしまな行為するわ
もう殺生するわ あらゆる悪をやるでしょ
全部私はというところから出てくる
ただそれだけで悪が残りなく消えてしまうのですと
ただそれだけで エッテテーパーパカアクサラダンマアパリセーサニルンジャンテ
一切悪が消えてしまいます
心がいたって簡単 私はというとこに執着しない
言語として使うのは構わない
本気になってはならん
釈尊はそれ以上語らず出ていくんです
これ 三段階で経典広げていくんです
まず ものすごいややこしいフレーズでバラモンに言う
それからいくらか理解できそうなような気分になるフレーズでお釈迦様は2番目に説明する
それ以上は言わない それで3段階目でハッキリとこれやというふうな説明が入るんです
マハーカッチャーナ尊者が詳しく解説します
それでお坊さんたちにはわからなくなって
お釈迦様の答えはね マハーカッチャーナ尊者のところに行って
教えてくださいと これはどんな意味かと
マハーカッチャーナ尊者が
まあなんであなた方 お釈迦様からじきじき聞いて
お釈迦様の説明を聞かないでこちらに来るんですかと
すごい断ったんです あまりにも教えてください
教えてくださいと言うんだから
まあ説明したんです で
これからもっと難しくなるかもしれません
眼耳鼻舌身意という我々の情報入る窓口があります
6つあります 眼耳鼻舌身意
まあ文字見たらわかるでしょう
目耳鼻とかね それに入るデータは色声香味触法というんですね
あまり詳しく知らなくても
窓口情報が入る窓口６つありまして
それぞれの情報が窓口で受け入れ
受けるんです 例えば 目はよくわかりやすいでしょ
目からこの形とか色の情報が受け入れるんですね
目は光をわかる 光は見えません
ですから 目に見えるのは形
色などなどなんです 耳には音しかわからないんで
だからはっきりと分かれています
耳でうどんが美味しいかどうかわからないでしょ？うどんが美味しいか知りたければ
これは口でやらないと
だから全くそれぞれ違う違うデータが六つの感覚 organに触れます
触れるんですよ ぶつかってくるんです
触れたら感じるんです
耳に音がドカンと触れると感じるんです
感じたものが概念を作るんですね
そこでパーリ語で感じたものという言葉を入れるんですね
感じるまでは私がいるという実感ないんです
それで音が触れて感じた瞬間で
あ 聞きます 聞こえたという
そこで私という錯覚がドカンと現れてくるんです
だから感覚がやばいんですよ
例えばちょっと寒いと感じるでしょ
私は寒いですね こう私が入るんですよ
ただ体がデータを認識しただけなんです
そこでドカンと私はということが入ってくるんです
それから我々は私はということは実体としているんだと思って
みんなそれで世界を作っちゃうんです
幻覚の世界 概念ができたら思考する
耳に音が触れたら感じて
あ 何か聞こえた あ 何ですか？ああ
なるほどなるほど そういうことを考えると
それで頭の中で思考するんです
ヤンウィタッケーティタンパパンチェーティ
次のステップ この思考を捏造する
だから思考するといったっても
なんか概念が生まれるだけですけど
それから概念を合わせて合わせてはっきりしたアイディアにするんです
それはパパンチェーキというんです
この思考を捏造する それから過去
現在 未来にわたって捏造概念を使う
だから私たちには過去があって未来があるでしょ
本当にないんですよ 頭の概念
妄想 概念 が その錯覚が起こるんです
でなきゃ過去はないんです
未来もないんです 実際にあるのは今だけなんです
そんなこと言ったってもね
頭の中ではね 2000年前に起きた出来事まで知ってるんだぞと思ってるでしょうにね
感じた瞬間で まあ我っていうね
我が起きているから パパンチャが起きているのです
そこで我々は体でデータを感じた瞬間で
もうパパンチャが出始めているんです
私は見た 私は感じて 私は聞こえたとかね
次に何を聞く？あ あれはね
もうこれこれこれこれ聞きましたよとか
それからの概念で考えているんですね
しかし 妄想することで
貪瞋痴などの感情と混じって悪性のパパンチになるんです
この我々がこの感情が入ってくると
もう妄想はしっかりと固定するんです
感情なければ別に聞いて終わっちゃいます
見てそれで終わっちゃいます
はい それでその経典のセクションが終わり
結構別な説明に入ります
はい これでポイントはスーッと一貫して私は同じことを喋ってます
目耳鼻にデータが触れたら
これがありともしないものに入れ替えちゃって
知った知ったとするんです
本当に我々の耳に何が触れるのか
目に何が触れるのかも知らないんですよ
もう頭でもう別なものを作っちゃうんです
それが捏造とも言うし
パパンチャとも言います 6
種類の津波の説明に入ります
眼耳舌身意に絶えず入る色声香味触法という情報を処理する仕方が間違っているので
幻想 捏造 概念ばかり起こるんです
観念を貪瞋痴の感情で知った
固めるんです だから私たちの生きているといっても
常に恐ろしい津波 ６つがぶつかっているんです
本当は津波ではないんですけど
目にものは見える それはしょうがないんですね
見えて触れて感じた瞬間から
これ津波にするんです
頭の中で 音が触れるところまでどうったことはないんです
触れて 音が触れて感じるでしょ
感じたところで我はということ出てきて
それからもう熱そうはするわ
怒りが出るわ 欲が出るわ
落ち込むわ あれやこれやとかね
激しい津波が起こるんです
それでいつでもこの体の中で６種類の津波が起きてるんだと覚えておいてください
それから津波ってあまり美しくないでしょ
だから悩み 苦しみが生まれるんです
どうにもならないでしょ
目 耳 鼻がある限り 舌がある限り
体で物事を感じる 感じられる限り
頭でいろんなことを考えられる限り
この津波が絶えず攻撃するんです
はい 別な経典に行きます
これはまたスッタニパータでアジタという結構頭のいい行者なんです
で 私は芸ですけど カットして対話にしたんです
アジタ設問します 世は何に覆われている？とブッダに聞くんです
ブッダの答えは無明に覆われている
いわゆるもう隠されていてわからないんですね
例えば花は綺麗ですかと言ってもわからないんです
無明であるんだ 無明ですから
私は綺麗と思う 猫は全然興味ない
で 花に来る ミツバチは綺麗と思う
花は別なのでしょ ミツバチにとっては別世界
ミツバチにも花に来るし
蝶々も来ますね じゃあもう花蜜吸うんだから同じだと思う
違います ミツバチは花に来てやっている仕事と蝶々が別なんです
また ミツバチにとってはあれは仕事場だからね
もう花粉を持っても花蜜を持っても運ばなくちゃいけない
蝶々は来てちょこちょこっと何か飲んで出ていくだけ
だからその昆虫二人にしても見方が違う
ですから これ正しいんじゃないんです
本当に花は何かと知らない
隠されていますね 我々は幻覚にいるんで
中にいるんです だから幻覚ではなくて
現実は見えない だからこの世はっていうのは
生命はなんです この生命たるものをはもう無知でしょうし
だから何に隠されてやられている
覆われているのかで お釈迦様
それは無明に覆われていますよと答える
２番目 なぜ発見しないんですかと
疑と放逸があるから と
ヴィーチャっていうのは疑でも訳できますけど
なんかどうだろう どうだろう
どうだろうっていう風にね
まあ心はしっかりしないっていうことは
集中力はないんですね
しっかりしないんですね
それから放逸  いい加減でいるんですよ
別に真剣じゃないんです
次の質問 この状況は固めるのは何か
幻想の回転ですと お釈迦様は答えるんです
我々も真理は知らないし
覆われているし しかし
みんなしっかり固めて
我輩はという感じで生きていますね
どうやってそんなにも
もう嘘なのに データはそんなにも胸張って知ってるそうと言えますかね
あれはね 妄想しているんだからよと
妄想すればするほど幻覚がしっかりするんです
もう治らなくなっちゃいます
その危険性は まあ危険がなければいいでしょう
危険ですよ 危険性は苦が起こることが危険です
妄想するのは別にいいんじゃないではないんで
妄想するたびにすごい苦しみが生まれるんです
はい そこで今日の紹介したのはこの芸なんです
次に美しい芸でアジタ行者がまた質問するんです
サワンティサッバディソータ
ソータナンキンニワラナン
ソータナンサンワランブーヒ
ケーナソータピティヤレ
あらゆる方向から心に絶えす流れが入り込む
私は流れの説明先にしましたね
ずっと流れてくるんですよ
絶えず 入り込む どうすれば止められますかと
目がある限り見えるでしょう
見えるたびにね 妄想するでしょう
だからそのたびに貪瞋痴が生まれるでしょう
次にまた妄想するでしょう
もうどうにもならない
あっという間に起こるんだから
だから心の速さ 仏教はチェックしているポイントもそれなんですよ
見えたその瞬間でもう妄想してるんです
その支配者です でお釈迦様の答え
ヤーニソータニロカスミン
サティテーサンニワラナン
ソータナンサンワランブーミ
パンニャーエーテピティヤレ
サティが世のこの流れに対する堤防ですと
やっとサティが来ました
智慧によってなくなりますと
だから このざーっと流れてくるこの津波に
六種の津波にとして堤防を作るんです
サティということで 気づきということで
堤防を作っただけで津波が攻撃します
堤防が頑丈ですから 苦しみはないんです
被害はないんです でもやばいでしょう
いくらなんでもそこでネッソーなくなっちゃうと死んで見えるんですよ
あ 今まで聞いた聞いたと思ったっても
本当は別やと 本物はと
それは知恵というんです
そういう知恵が現れたら
パパンチはしなくなっちゃうんです
それで終わり だからサティとパンチャンですね
はあ すごい苦労しました
サティの説明をするために
もうわかってますかね
サティっていうのは 気づきっていうのは
そんな単純なことじゃないんだ
ないんだと 一般人に俗世間に理解できることじゃないんです
これは生命そのものの問題なんです
生きるというそのものの問題なんです
生きるとは知ることなんです
知るとは捏造することなんです
そこは私は最初に言ったでしょ
どうにもならんがと これはと
世間の誰にもどうにもならんですけど
ブッダが答えを見つけたんです
こういうやり方あるんだよ
はい まあと かなりやりますけど
まあこれからサティの説明に入りますけど
皆様疲れていらっしゃるでしょうしね
ちょっと  はい では 10 分間休憩いたします
では始まります あのまあ
これからまあサティの説明ですけど
まあ前よりもなんかややこしくなるかもしれませんだけど
別にこのこのセクションは別にあまりわからなくても大したことはないんです
一番大事なところは前のセクションです
あのサティの気づきの働き
パパンチャ あれは捏造ですね
煩悩 妄想 概念の かき回しをストップする堤防として働くんです
だから この気づきっていうことは
我々日常で喋っている
気づいた 気づいたと そんなもんじゃないんです
それとまるっきり違うんです
よく覚えてください 気づきっていうのは毎日使ってますからね
あんた気づいた？はいはい
知ってます そんな程度じゃなくて
これはもうものすごい違う働きなんです
捏造 妄想 概念 思考する
このややこしい この内回転する
この幻覚 回転を堤防をかけてストップさせることです
日常で使う気づきという語と意味が完全に違います
それから英語で気づくアウェアネスと訳するでしょ
そんなもんじゃないんです
捏造という津波に堤防として働く時のみ
仏道が語るサティです
皆様にヴィパッサナー瞑想で教えているサティもありますね
それだけサティなんです
気づきです 本物の だから日常の気づきは
この中に入らないんです
あ 気づいたとかいうのは
もう全然瞑想でもなんでもないんです
これがこの心理学的に常に生命がある限り起きている
このシステムにストップかけることだから
もうそうそうたる大変なことなんです
存在そのものの流れに関わる仕事なんです
その時 仏教の専門用語のサティです
気づきによって心の激しい荒波がなくなって静まってくると
ありのままに知ることができるんです
この捏造する幻覚を作ることに堤防をかけてやめちゃうと
もうデータがそのまま入るんです
そうするとありのままに知ることができるんです
それは承知というんです
サンパジャンニャ それで智慧が現れます
その時の発見は智慧と言います
妄想がやめたらどうなるのかと心配でしょ？妄想をやめたら
こういう幻覚世界消えちゃいます
消えて幻覚を作る以前のデータが入ってくるんです
私はよく出すわかりやすい例があります
この死んだドブネズミを持ってきて
カラスと私が見る それで私が気持ち悪いと見えるでしょ
カラスにはなんで美味しいか
これを奪って食べてやるぞとカラスは思ってるでしょ
おかしいね だから気持ち悪いかごちそうかわからへんでしょ
それは捏造の世界 しかし
私の目にもカラスの目にも同じデータ触れたんです
それを知っておくんです
捏造する前に だから私は気持ち悪いと思った
同じデータがカラスの目に触れたらごちそうという結論になるんです
だから気持ち悪いのはパパンチャでごちそうというカラスのカラスの考えはパパンチャで
笹の葉っぱにしたっても同じことですよ
で パンダがおいしそうと思っちゃうし
それパパンチャで 私たちはなんだ
笹の葉ですか？と思っちゃうし
しかし 同じものを見ているはずなんです
見えたデータは何なのかで
それがあるがまま かなり大変な世界ですよ
ありのままという言葉さえも
それで発見することで智慧というんです
智慧が現れたら パパンチャが停止する
一切の苦しみから脱出する
で終わり 仏教の修行は
言うのは簡単です  1 秒のもう 1 万分の 1 でももう捏造するんです
妄想するんです だから相当修行しないと
はい 別な経典にあります
これはあの本を出してます
本かな チャッターリーサーリッタの
八正道 八正道大全というやつで
ホームページから PDF でも読めますので
よろしかったら読んでください
本は出してます ホームページからダウンロードできそうだそうです
で もうちょっと触れてみたいと思います
仏道は正見が頭として始まります
だって幻覚に反対するならば正見でしょ
だからいきなり幻覚を破れませんだけど
もうちょっと真面目に
ちょっと物事を見ることでもしてもらわないと
この真面目に本気になって本当のことをしろよという気持ちが正見で
そこから仏道が始まるんです
俗世間的で善なる正見と解脱を司る正見と 2つあります
お釈迦様がバージョン 2つで語ってます
一般一般人バージョンと専門バージョンという
正見というのは正しい見解であってね
まあ悪いことをしてはいけませんとかね
で 良いことをしましょうっても正見でしょ
でもそんなのはあまりも一般的なバージョンで
もう一つは 正見というのは悟りを目指す正見があるんです
正見で邪見をなくすために精進する
で それも邪見もバージョン 2ついつでも
で 皆様が知っている邪見をなくすことも正見ですけど
仏道が言ってる邪見っていうのはパパンチャなんです
捏造することなんです
ものはあると私がいると思うことが邪見です
だから 2つあります それで正見はなんで育てるのかというと
この邪見を を壊すためなんです
簡単には壊せませんだから精進しないとね
それは八正道の正精進というんです
そこでサティが入るんです
やっと 正念 だから正見と正精進と気づき
この 3つで成功するんです
気づきがないとどうにもならん
正見つきますと言ったっても
なんか麻原が瞑想を教えたような感じで
瞑想します 瞑想しますと叫んでるんです
私は行ってみたんですからね
これで最終解脱になっているんだから
だからそんなのは だから正見正見で言ったんだからで正見になりません
かなり頭の中にある間違った概念を取り除いて
勉強して勉強して かなり苦労しながら正精進ですね
しかし 根絶をストップするためにはサティがどうしても必要です
正見を中心に正見 正精進
正念が働くんです だから正見育てようというふうに出しちゃうと
それにはファクター 3つ必要です
正見 正精進 正念 正念と一般的に訳するんだから
この単語を使いましたけど
これはサティなんですね
正しい気づき 八正道の 2番目は正思惟と言うんですね
それは思考のことを考えることですけどね
それで欲 異常 怒り 害を与えたくなる感情をなくすことが正思惟と言うんです
いきなり思考を止めなさいと仏教は言いません
正しい思考しなさいと
正しい思考ってわかったものじゃないでしょ
でしたら 怒りの思考 欲の思考と人に害を与えたいという思考はストップしなさいと
それだけ他は OK です
それは一般人のレベル
上級者 悟りを目指す人はもっと違います
解脱になると一切の思考
概念 論 言語を使用をストップするんです
結構レベル違うでしょ
一般的に我々説法するときは
正思惟とは欲の思考をやめること
怒りの思考 怒りといったっても激しい怒り
欲といったってもご飯食べたいという程度の欲じゃないんです
ラーメン食べたい ご飯
あれも欲ですけど それはもう OK です
激しい欲と激しい怒り
それはやめてくださいと
それから人に害を与えたいというね
しかし それで悟れませんよ
悟るための思考停止っていうのは
一切頭の中で言語をストップさせるんです
言語 単語さえ使えないところまでストップさせるんです
概念 根絶 すべて そうすると悟れます
それって相当正精進しなきゃダメです
それでまたサティが入ってくるんです
そのために精進する気づきで思考を止める
したがって 正見 正精進
正念が正思惟を中心に働く
そこで思考ストップというポイントから始めても同じこっちゃ
正見が必要です 正精進が必要です
気づきが必要です この八正道は輪っかですから
どこから始めてもいいんです
それで八正道の次  3番目
正語 いわゆる悪い言葉を語るなかれと
あの 喋らなくちゃあかんから
人間だから その場合は悪い言葉やめて
いい言葉を喋りなさいということですね
それが一般人にそう言うんです
嘘を言うなよ 無駄話言うなよと
噂を言うなよと 荒っぽい粗悪語
きつい言葉 それだけやめてください
4つだけやめてくださいと
他自由に喋ってよと言うんです
何喋ってもいいんです
しかし 嘘と 噂話と無駄話と粗悪語
厳しい言葉だけ気をつける
それでは悟りません 悟りに達するために正語を実践する人が
言語が喋りたいというあの衝動が生まれるでしょう
それをなくすんです あーこれ喋りたいな
これがなくなっちゃうんです
それで完璧 正語でしょ？何も喋ってない
喋ってないどころか 喋りたいというエネルギーも起きてこないんです
これは悟りのレベル だからいつでも八正道は二つ
バージョン二つ 八正道の正語
正命 正精進にも同じ形で説明します
まあ省略しましょう 八正道で八ですからね
あの正語っていうのは体でやること
一般人に言うのは殺生してはいけません
よくしめの行為をやめてください
それから盗みだけやめてくださいと
他は OK です 仏教ってすごい親切でしょ
三つしか あの 殺生はやめてくださいと
盗むことをやめてください
よこ あの よこしまなことをやめてくださいと
他 別にゲートボールはいいんです
ゴルフも構わない 他の行動には制限してないんです
それ イスラム教と比較してみるとね
あれやこれや 禁止 禁止
禁止 禁止ばっかしで しかしそれ程度では悟りません
だから 何かやりたいという心で出てくる
あの衝動を抑えておく
ストップするんです これがあの
皆様なんか力がなくなっちゃうかもしれません
だけど大丈夫です 瞑想をやってみるってやっていると
どんどん集中力が上がって
そこはそのプロセスが自動的に起こりますからね
その時でも正見が必要し
正精進が必要でしょうし
気づきが必要です はい
次のポイントは まああの
これはあの リクエストに応じてやりましたけどね
あのサンマーサティっていうのは八正道にあります
正しい気づき 時々経典ではこのあの対でペアで語るときもあります
正見と邪見 まあ言語学的にペアが現れますからね
だからサンマアディティ
ミッチャーディティ 正思惟と邪思惟と
そうなってくると 正念と邪念という風に出てきます
それで あの なんか日本語おかしいね
邪念となんか言ったらね
正しい気づきと間違ってる気づきという単語が出てくるんです
これって何かと 正見で邪見をなくす
正思惟で邪思惟をなくす
正念で邪念をなくす 正定で邪定をなくすとあるが
あります サティとサマーディのミッチャーバージョンの説明はありません
経典にはないんです 昨日
ずーっと徹夜して全部調べたんです
朝六時まで 大量のデータ
で ないんです  調べなくたってもないってこと知ってましたけどね
ちょっと調べて言わなきゃね
もう良くないんだから
面白いこと この この正見邪見リストが出てくる経典がありまして
そこでその時一つ一つ定義するんです
正見とは何や 邪見とは何やとかね
ものすごく詳しいんですよ
それで少年になってきたら
するっと次に行くんです
あの経典のスタイルもフォーマットもないんです
その場合は  わかりやすい答えはね
サティはあくまでも特別な心理学的な機能なんです
一般人々は知るはずもないんです
ブッダが初めて発見したんです
だから ミッチャーサティはという用語はありえないんです
サティも発見していない人は
どうやって間違ったサティを発見できますかね
それからサマーディの場合も
あのミッチャーサマーディということはよくありますけど
あれはありえないんです
サマーディっていうのは禅定の定です
心統一したら これは禅なんです
だからそれは存在しないんです
あの言語で作れるんだからといってないんです
ウサギの角と同じです
言語では成り立ちますけど
実際はないんです 気づきは仏教特有の用語で
俗世間の気づきと違うという意味ですよ
例えばもう銀行強盗するためにも相当気づきが必要でしょ
あの警報がね もう動かないようにとかね
警備員に見つからないようにとか
相当気づいて気づいて気づいて
もう年に年を重ねてね
頑張ってますよ でも あれは仏道に入ってる少年の反対じゃないんで
あれはもうただまあ 俗世間の気づきなんです
はい 気づきの意味 一般的な気づきを意味するサティは
解脱を司る心の働きという意味で仏教用語になってますかな
まあただ あの仏教用語は世の中にみんな使ってる単語
気づいた はい 気づきました
その単語を使ってるんですが
意味が違います だからいろいろ意味があります
1解脱に達する修行法
それは仏教の用語ですね
解脱の達する修行法って何かとスーッと説明しました
四諦を理解することです
それから不放逸という単語がございまして
パーリ語でアッパマーラと読むんですね
言葉は違いますが サティとおなじみです
お釈迦様は涅槃に入る
ギリギリ最後の言葉 不放逸で
頑張ってください と いわゆるサティなんです
サティで悟りです で あのサティアッパマーラっていうのはこの言葉 2つですけど
この偈作ったり アッパマードウアマタパダンと言ったら美しいでしょうに
だからその文学的に美しい単語をそのそのそのその使います
で スッタニパータなどなどでは
短い偈だからだいたいサティという言葉を使ってます
2番目の意味は記憶 作用
人の日常の気づきにはサティは使いません
おそらくアビダンマでいうアビモッカという信条だと思います
それは専門家のために説明はしません
あのアビダンマで信条がありまして
アビダンマの信条の場合でも
サティは善信条で決まってるんです
悪信条じゃないんです
では我々もね ゲームやってる時もよく集中してやってるでしょうね
なんかやる時はやっぱりかなり気づいて
電車に乗る時は足元に気づくでしょ
まあそんな それはそれも俗世間の気づきなんですね
カバンがドアに挟まらないようにとか
だから電車に乗る時はカバンちゃんと中に入れて中に入るでしょう
あれもなんか気づきのように見えますが
あれで悟りませんからね
思考はストップになりませんだからね
だからその気づきに差がありますね
例えば もうルイ・ヴィトンのカバンを持って電車に乗って
満員電車でなかなか中に入りにくいんですけど
強引に入ったと これがドアに挟まれたらお金もったいないでしょう
だからちゃんと気づいて
いくら人混みであっても
カバンだけはつぶれないようにとすっと気をつけて
ここら辺に持ってきて
大事に電車に乗るんですね
あれも気づいてよく頑張ってるんですが
結果は欲が生まれるだけ
欲と怒り 嫌になっちゃいますね
もうブレーキかけるとまた人がぶつけてカバンがもうしわでも出たら大変だからね
だからカバンに対する欲と
カバンがちょこっとでもダメージ受けたら大変だって
怒りとかね だからあのサティで欲と怒りが生まれるだけなんですね
俗世間の気づきでは ですから
それは仏教用語ではありません
怒り 欲がなくす気づきが仏教のサンマーサティなんです
だから まあ他のサティは全部ミッチャーサティと思っちゃえば簡単でしょう
はい 修行としての気づき
四念処経サティパッターナスッタですね
説かれている方法のみです
この気づきっていうのは
皆様 今パティパターナに一部一部出してますけど
四念処経という経典があります
これはサティパッターナ
どのように気づきを成立するのか
作り上げるのかという経典なんです
気づきの作り方かな 作り上げる
成り立ち方とかね という経典がありまして
そちらで教えています
その方法だけ 気づきです
サンマーサティです だから
あのジョブスさんが作っている APPLE 製品と同じく
もう他とは何の相性もなく
それだけでクローズドシステムですね
だから気づき は仏教の修行であって
それはクローズドシステムです
何でもかんでもできるわけじゃないんです
特にお釈迦様はカーヤヌパッサナー
体に気づいてくださいと
その経典 今日は時間ないんだから紹介できませんだけど
例えがありまして 海を見ろよと
海を見ると膨大な海ですけど
地球世界にあるすべての川が海に入りますよ
そこで一緒になります
そのように体のことに気づけば
すべての善がそちらに揃ってきますよと
来て解脱に達しますよと
だから この歩く瞑想 座る瞑想やいろいろ言ってる体の動きに気づいて気づいていくことは
サンマーサティ正念あるいは正しい気づき
私は本を読んでいると少年ね
それはありえません 音楽の好きな人と
私は音楽を作る時は 作曲している時はずっと集中してサティでやってますよと
できません それに入りません
その仏教の専門的な特別のサティは
あれは四念処経のサティだけです
だからワンファット 唯一の道であるとハッキリと書かれています
エーカーヤノアヤンビッカレマッゴーサッターナンヴィスッディア
ソーカパリッドワーナンサマティグマーセナーヤサジグマーエニッバーナサッチキリアヤ
ヤディダンチャッターロサティワッターノ
というふうにあります
体に感覚に 心に 法に徹して気づく訓練ですね
正しいサンマーサティは
実践者は言葉を使って訓練します
これは昔からもうブッダの時代からも
やっぱりあの 我々はずっと言葉にはめられてますから
言葉を使って気づきの実践をするんです
サティの実践をするんです
しかし 言葉は概念であり
妄想であり 捏造でもあります
なんかややこしい 言葉を使ってサティを実践しますけど
言葉っていうのは捏造ですけど
どうしますかね ですから
真剣に精密に現在の現象にのみ確認
気づきを行うんです だから捏造になるのは過去に行っちゃうと
将来に行っちゃうとなんです
だから厳密に今の体 今の瞬間に言葉をかけるんです
ものすごい難しいんですけど
それで妄想の穴に落ちないんです
やってみたらいたって簡単でしょ？今の瞬間に実況するともうすぐ入りませんだから
左足上げる運ぶ下ろす
それだけ真剣にやったら
何の妄想も入る余地がないんです
言葉使ってるんですけど
それから自分の体以外に意識が行かないように心を内向にするんです
このサティの実践するときは
このスペース以外のところに持っていかないんです
体でやるんです 正しい
今正しいここなんです
正しいではなくて まさに今
まさにここ そこで言葉で瞑想すればいいんです
しかし まさに今でなければ
まさにここでなければダメなんです
ライトナウ ライトヒアなんです
これがポイントです だからそういうところ
そういう風にやってやりませんし
だから私に対立していろいろやり
勝手なやり方やりますから
結果ないだけで 私は精密にお釈迦様の経典に純粋精密に教えているはずなんです
他のお坊さんたちはいろいろいろいろみんなに合わせて調整してしまいます
私はやりません はい 次の説明
この記憶にもサティというんですね
これはパーリ語を知っている人が悩む問題で
皆様には別にもう関係ないんですけど
これ結構ダブってしまいます
あのパーリ語でもダブってるんです
注釈草でもダブってるんです
どちらでしょうかって
なんかわからなくなっちゃったりするんですね
明確に記憶というと 規則気づきが区別しようとしてないんです
定義もないし あんまり気にしてないみたい
だから日本学する学者の先生方も
もうちょこちょことごちゃごちゃになるのはまあしょうがないんです
昔からもあんまり区別してないんですね
記憶能力が高く評価します
理由があります 仏教はこの記憶能力っていうのをすごいいいことやと思ってますよ
記憶喪失というのは頭が悪いって意味でしょ
ものを忘れちゃったら
もう脳が壊れてるんだから
だから頑張っても死ぬ瞬間までもよくしっかりと
もう脳だけは元気で 体が壊れてもいられるようにしなくちゃいけない
それは仏教 すごく高く評価するものなんですね
だから まあダブってまずいっていうことは気にしてないんです
記憶がよく記憶力あるっていうことは悪いことじゃないんです
サティの反対はムッタサティです
それは別なポイントですけど
集中力がない 放逸 心が弱い
混乱している 物忘れ だらしないという意味なんです
ムッタサティといえばだらしない
だらしないの反対はサティがあるってことなんです
だから記憶とダブっちゃいます
ムッタサティって言ったら
なんの物忘れ 今言ったこと今忘れたでしょうにとかね
なんだあなたはという状態なんです
例えば授業をやっているのに
生徒たちが全然聞いてない
空を見てたり あっち見たりこっち見て
あれはムッタサティているんです
だからじっと聞いていると
気づきでもありながら記憶もできますでしょ
だから機能としてもなんとなく似ています
ですから 意味は 間違う可能性もあります
翻訳したりすると間違う可能性ありますから
よく気をつけなくちゃいけない
記憶で翻訳するか 気づきで翻訳するかっていうことはね
定義見るとびっくりします
これはアビダンマテキストやらいろんなテキストにある定義で
いい加減な定義なんです
タッタカタマサティ ヤーサティアヌッサティパティッサティ
サティサラナタダーナタアピラーパナタアサンムサナタ
サティサティインドリヤンサティバランサッマーサティアヤンムッチャティサティ
何の定義にもなりません
これはアビダンマの定義の仕方です
で ちょっと難しい単語並んでますから
ちょっと訳はちょっと遠慮します
いくらか訳します サティとは気づき
随念 思い出す 記憶する
呼び出す 混乱していない
念根 念力 正念などなどはサティであると
だからどんな単語使っても構わないよという意味なんですね
飛びます これ アピラーパナッタという単語が定義の同義語の中に呼び出す
注意を呼び出すという意味を使って修行のサティを説明してあります
まあもうこのセクション
ちょっとまあなんか知識っぽくなっちゃいますから
あまり気持ち悪いんですけど
あの 修行する人のサティって何でしょうかというと
この注釈書やらいろんなところでこのアピラーパナスという言葉を使うんです
アピラーパナっていうのは
この呼び出す なんかおかしく感じますね
呼び出す 皆様 何も呼び出してないですよ
瞑想する時は これ 例えがあって
それで意味がわかります
これ ミリンダパンニャというテキストからです
天林王の大蔵大臣は毎日王にどれぐらい財産があるのかと説明します
ストーリーでね 天林王がいて
まあどんな王かわかりませんだけど
どうでもいいでしょう
まあ天林王がいて 天林王っていうのは世界全部を支配する王っていう感じですけどね
正しく で 彼には抜群の天才能力ある大臣がいるんですね
大蔵大臣が あの昔の人々の考えだからね
昔の国って小さいでしょ
だから国の財産って言ったっても
王様の個人財産だからね
それで税金などなど持っていったって
王様のポケットに持っていくだけで
それで軍隊養って王様はもう政治してるんですね
だから一人でいいんだけど
もし最低インド全体的に支配する王になったっても
大蔵大臣ではできないと思いますけど
大蔵省が石やと思いますけど
ものすごい人が仕事をする
まあそれはまあもう昔のことだからいいんだけど
そこでこの大蔵大臣が
王様が朝仕事始めたら
王様にどれぐらい財産があるのかと報告するんです
王様には象は 368頭いますよと
で 馬はこれぐらいですよと
宝石はこれぐらい 金はこれぐらいとかね
それで王様にある財産ですけど
呼び出すんですね それはアピラープナというんです
読み上げるんです これでヴィパッサナー瞑想ですかね
ぴったしヴィパッサナー瞑想になるんです
なぜかというと 王様 去年はこれぐらいお金ありましたとは言わないんです
今お送らなる財産だけ報告するんです
あ ここ象は 200頭  200頭ですけど
まあ来年はやっぱり 300頭になるだろうとかね
そんなアホなこと言ったら王様に時間なくなりますから
だから現在のものは言うんですね
それでこのサティパッターナ経典を読んでみると
例えば体を見てくださいと
体を見る方法はいろいろあります
一つは体を破って割って中身を見る
これが腸 これが大腸 これは小腸
これは肺 これはあれやこれやると 32に分ける
見るでしょ そのやり方なんですね
今あるもの だから痛みが出たら痛み
快感が出たら快感と こんな風に座ったら痛みが出るだろうと言ったらアウト
こんなところで座って瞑想すると
もう冷えるんじゃない？と
もうアウト それは妄想です
座って瞑想すると体が冷えてきたら冷やけとそれだけ確認する
それはコールバック 呼び出すことなんです
現実をさらに呼び出してみるんですね
それで妄想ができなくなります
そういう定義ですね 今
現在の状況をあえて心に入れることがサティです
はい また随念もサティと随念を一緒にしているんです
何かテーマ対象を決めて
それを心で追うことが随念です
何かテーマを決めて それずっとっていくんです
それに随念と言うんです
アヌッサティと言うんです
アビダンマの定義では
サティとアヌッサティはもう同じや同じです
受験勉強も随念の一種ですね
受験勉強するときは その学生さんが何かテーマを決めて
じゃあ数学やります じゃあこれやりますとかね
で それを追っていくんですね
それ随念です 慈悲喜捨の瞑想
仏随念 呼吸随念などはサマーディ瞑想です
それも随念です テーマ決めます
じゃあ慈悲の瞑想をしますと
だから慈悲の概念だけ追っておくんです
だから随念でもありながら瞑想でもありますし
サティも働いてますし
えーと サマーディ状態が生まれます
間違っているもあります
一神教の神を念じる 呪文を唱える
真言を唱えるなども一応随念ですが
だってテーマを決めてやっていますからね
テーマを決めて追っているんだから
一応随念です 妄想幻想を強引に作ることになります
とんでもないことになります
だって神って妄想でしょ
これ随念すると あのロータリーというやつを持って
ロータリーなんでしたっけ？お数を持って念じると
頭がまあどうなることかと
それから真言という宗教ではいっぱい真言を唱えるでしょ
あれも結構素晴らしいんですよ
頭イカれる目的だったら
で 幻覚は起こるんです
あの 言ったらあかんですけどね
まあ人の悪口はね 悪口で言っても本当のことだからね
例えば浄土系の宗教では念仏というね
仏典には仏教でもありますよ
その場合は如来の徳を念じるんです
して 頑張らなくちゃという気分になるんです
念仏は違います 存在もしない
頭で考えて阿弥陀様ということを考えて念じるでしょ
そうすると幻覚が起こります
それは仏教が推薦しない
仏教の随念といえば呼吸
それから体の不浄 地水火風とかね
そういう客観的なものになるんです
慈悲喜捨 四念処経の体に気づくことも
随念の形にもなります
四念処経では体を どうやって気づくのかっていうたくさんリストがありまして
その中に呼吸瞑想も入ってますしね
だからこの随念もサティもだいたい一緒に使ってるんです
そこで心が汚れる 幻覚が起こる
随念はミッチャーサティではないでしょうかと
私の勝手な結論ですね
幻覚を引き起こす  お化けがいるんだ
いるんだって随念するとお化け見えちゃいますからね
科学者 学者の研究も随念になります
例えば科学者が何かテーマを決めて
ずーっともう飲まず食わず研究するでしょ
あれも一つテーマを追っていくことだから随念です
学者も自分でテーマを決めて研究するんだから
何年も 随念ですけど 貪瞋痴が消えるか増えるかということがポイントです
結局貪瞋痴が増えるでしょ
だからそれはまあミッチャーサティですね
サティはサティですけど
ミッチャー それでは心は良くならないんだよと
正しい気づき 気づきも随念もダブったりしますが
問題ではありません 妄想
熱想をなくすこと 煩悩をなくすこと
集中力が上がってサマーディが起こることのみが起こること
それだけのみが正しい気づき
正念です それで結論です
何のことなく終わりました
で 最後の方であれ 正しいサンマーサティとは
まあそういう集中力は上がって上がる上がること
心が清らかになること
幻覚はなくなること 智慧が現れることですね
その目的の気づきがサンマーサティで
他知らないぞと ですからミッチャーサティの説明はないんです
経典では 一応今日はミッチャーサティって何なのかっていうことは
まあこの勉強する方々のために一応紹介しました
話はそれで終了します
ありがとうございます
今日はちょっと会場の時間の都合でですね
修行等は割愛させていただきます
すみません ちょっと皆さん最後に回向の文を皆さんでお唱えして終了したいと思います
合掌してください 回向の文
仏法僧の三宝に礼拝敬し
戒を守り 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー修行によって生まれたこの功徳を
神々 先祖 祖父母 両親 親族
恩師をはじめとし 一切の生きとし生けるものに回向いたします
この功徳によって すべての生きとし生けるものが幸福に暮らせますように
そして解脱が得られますように
サンビーティーオイバンジャントーサンバローゴーウィナッサトーマーテーバワットアンタラーヨースケーディーガーユコーバワーバウォトゥサッバマンガランラッカント
ーサンバデーヴァタサンバブッダヌバーヴェーナサンバダンマヌバーヴェーナサッバサンガーヌバーヴェーナサダー スッティバワントーティーアビワダナシーリース
ーニッチャンワッダーパチャイノーチャッターローダンマーワッダンティーヤーイワンノーシュカンバラン
サーーデューサーーデューサーーデュー
どうもありがとうございます